bon nicolas il est 16 heures je dois
aller à la mosquée c'est l'heure de la
prière ok pas de problème
merci pour ces informations hassan
quitte subitement son poste hassan
il peut y par alamos la mosquée on a une
mosquée sur l'île et cinq fois par jour
donc ils se rendent à la mosquée pour la
prière la plupart des touristes ne le
savent pas mais l'archipel des maldives
est une république islamique
l'islam est la religion d'état la
première règle lorsque l'on veut ouvrir
un resort c'est construire une mosquée
pour les employés il y en a une sur
chaque île du pays qui cause tant que
musulmans nous devons nous rendre à la
mosquée pour prier cinq fois par jour
quoique nous soyons en train de trouver
du travail ou n'importe quoi d'autre
nous nous arrêtons quand c'est l'heure
et nous venons à la mosquée ensuite nous
retourne travailler les maldiviens sont
particulièrement religieux dans les
hôtels ils ne peuvent pas travailler
derrière un bar à cause de l'alcool dans
les cuisines à cause du port ni dans
l'espace pour cause de nullité
ce n'est pas un problème du tout nous
aimons travailler avec les étrangers et
découvrir différentes cultures
ça ne me pose aucun souci de rencontrer
des gens d'autres religions
et pourtant aujourd'hui dans certains
resort le mode de vie des occidentaux
est mal accepté par le personnel
maldivien sur ces images amateurs
un couple de suisses est en train de
renouveler ses voeux de mariage
cette cérémonie est très courante aux
maldives
mais pendant la célébration l'employé en
profite pour insulter en maldivien le
couple de touristes des propos injurieux
à caractère religieux
sur internet la vidéo a été visionnée
plusieurs centaines de milliers de fois
créant une vague d'indignation
l'employé été identifiés et condamnés à
cinq jours de prison
cette vidéo en dit long sur l'évolution
des maldives pour découvrir l'autre
visage de l'archipel il faut sandra malé
la capitale malé c'est l'île la plus
peuplée au monde
plus de cent mille habitants s'entassent
sur à peine deux kilomètres carrés là
bas changement d'ambiance
la plupart des femmes portent le voile
la consommation d'alcool est passible
d'emprisonnement
si vous marchez dans la rue vous verrez
certainement qu'aujourd'hui il y a plus
de personnes conservatrice qui portent
le voile pendant très longtemps les
maldiviens pratiquer un islam modéré
mais les premières élections
démocratiques en 2008 ont donné une voix
plus importante à un parti islamique à
dalat des imams formés au pakistan et en
arabie saoudite prêcherait même dans
certaines mosquées de malley